-Our first guest tonight
is a Grammy-nominated musician
a Jonas brother, and a coach
on this season of "The Voice,"
which airs live episodes
on Monday and Tuesday nights
right here on NBC.
Please welcome back to the show,
one of my favorite people
to day drink with, Nick Jonas!
How are you, Nick?
-Hi. How are you?
-I'm doing well.
I did hear you say
you recently had a biking
accident, and you cracked a rib.
How are you doing?
-I'm good. When I sit uprigh
like this, I'm totally fine.
But, yeah, it's been a weird
couple days recovering fro
a rib injury because
they basically tell you
at the hospital,
"There's nothing we can do."
-Right.
-And so you just have to
wait it out.
But, you know, it's all good
-Did you know
when you hit the ground
that something had cracked
-Yeah.
Well, we were shooting something
for NBC, my brothers and I
-Gotcha.
-And it was a competitive thing.
But we all looked at each othe
beforehand because the rac
was actually,
you know, pretty intense.
We said, "Just take it easy.
Let's not overdo it."
And so I was being responsible
I wasn't being
overly competitive.
But just something happened.
It was one of those things
where the steering wheel
or whatever --
the handle bars just kind of
got out from under me,
and I just tumbled, man.
And when I hit the ground,
I actually felt like, "Oh, no.
I'm gonna hurt one of my
brothers," because we're all
like, this close racing.
But then when I got up, I was,
like, "Nope, nope, it's me
It's me."
-On the upside, at least,
it happened while you're
doing something for NBC
and you get that workers' comp
-Exactly.
But I have the other show
for NBC, "The Voice."
[ Laughter ]
But I get to sit in a chai
for that the whole time, too
so that's fine.
-That's true.
Hey, before we move on,
I mean, you were one of
the last people
I had a civilized drink with
when we went day drinking
with our brothers and our
friend, Jack McBrayer.
We drank your tequila.
-Which was just
way too much fun.
-That was a lot of fun.
We had some Villa One then
And I'm gonna pour some now, and
I think you've got some there.
How have you been --
How've you been drinking yours
Have you been drinking mor
or less during the past year
-Funny you should ask.
[ Laughter ]
You know, I would say I've
probably been drinking more...
-Yeah.
-...because I've just been home,
not working as much.
And, you know, being a founder
and a fan of this tequila
that we created,
I think it's important just to
do some market research
of my own and just make sure..
-Of course.
-...it's good still, you know?
And, in fact, it is, so...
-Well, cheers to you.
I know from experience
that it's a very good tequila.
-Yes.
-And I thank you very much
for sending it.
I, myself, have not seen
my brother much this year
because he's in L.A.,
and I, obviously,
am in New York.
You live right
down the street from Joe.
Have you managed to see hi
a fair amount?
-I have, yeah.
Priyanka and I have been
spending a lot of time in
the U.K. as well as the U.S.
because she's shooting
over there.
So coming back and forth thi
year, which has been nuts.
But when I'm here in L.A.,
Joe and Sophie are just,
you know, 7 to 10 minutes away
depending on the L.A. traffic.
And we see each other quit
a lot, which is really nice.
But, you know, when
I'm in London, obviously,
little harder to see each other.
-Yes.
You -- I think this is
very exciting not just for you
but your fans.
You and your brothers are gonn
perform again for the first time
in a long time, obviously,
at Summerfest in Milwaukee
I will tell you,
I think it's just gonna be a
boom time for live performance
Is that your expectation,
that it will be so excitin
not just to be performing
in front of audiences agai
but audiences that haven't
been out for over a year?
-Yeah.
Well, you know, I think that
obviously, this last
year and a half
has been insane
for everybody.
And now that it
feels like things,
at least here in the U.S., are
kind of getting back to normal
I think there is definitel
an appetite for live shows
I know that I am craving,
you know, a live show,
and I feel really lucky
in that I get to sit in a chai
and watch great vocalists sing
every Monday and Tuesday
right in front of me.
But as far as getting back
on stage, I know I can't wait,
the brothers can't wait,
and I'm hopeful that the fan
and people feel ready
to come out and celebrate,
hopefully, the kind of
turning point
of this whole thing.
-Do you think you'll have to d
more rehearsal than usual?
Do you feel as though you guys
will be rusty, or do you think
you'll pick it
right back up again?
-Well, I think Joe might.
-Yeah, I thought so, too.
-He requires just
a little bit extra rehearsal
to remember lyrics.
-Yeah.
-Even while we're on tour,
he can't remember them.
So a year and a half off,
we'll see if he can stick it
-I asked because,
if you hadn't said that,
we were gonna recommend mayb
getting Joe
in the rehearsal room a little
bit more than the rest of you.
[ Laughter ]
-So you know.
You know us too well
at this point.
-You're also hosting --
And this is going to be
in a theater with an audience,
the Billboard Awards?
-Yeah. So they've done something
really cool.
That the set is, you know,
basically kind of an
indoor/outdoor situation
with people
that have been vaccinated,
and, you know,
it's gonna be a celebration of a
strange but great year in music.
And, you know,
the fact that they asked m
to host is such an honor,
and I just can't wait
to get out there and, again,
listen to some live music.
It's been so long.
And the fact that there's
gonna be real fans there
will be really special.
-So, I want to ask about
"The Voice," as we mentioned
I guess we'll be down --
when this airs,
we'll be down to nine
contestants.
And how have you felt so far
about the season?
-Actually, I think at this point
we've just locked in
our finalists.
So, you know,
who knows what could happen?
It's up to America to decide now
who wins this thing.
And that's kind of the brilliant
part about this show is,
you know, the coaches,
we get it.
You know, we make the decision
up until the live shows,
which started
a couple weeks ago.
And then America decides.
And we're often surprised
by who, you know, they fee
they want to bring to the finale
and who they don't, which
is also very surprising.
Because we have our favorites,
of course, but it's up to them
And so I'm blown away
by the talent this year
and just the fact that
20 seasons into the show,
they're still finding people
who are so brilliant
is pretty impressive.
-So, last year,
were you surprised
that you finished second
to Blake Shelton?
Because I asked him, and he said
he wasn't surprised at all
that he won.
-Yeah, well, he's a liar.
-Yeah.
-Okay. Let's put that
on the table, first of all
He was shocked he won.
-But such a charming liar,
don't you think, as liars go
-A charming liar.
I was so mad.
You know, we were shooting
the live shows
last year in quarantine,
so we were all at home.
So I didn't really get to,
like, address him head on
and tell him
how frustrated I was.
But he certainly lit up
the text thread
with all of us just gloating
So this year,
we can't let that happen again
He's got some very talente
people on his team.
But this would be his eighth win
if he wins, which is insane.
I mean, he's been there
from the beginning.
So I don't know,
the numbers game, it's --
you know, it is what it is
But he's kind of poised to be in
a good spot with this one, too
He's got some great people
-He's the Tom Brady
of "Voice" coaches.
-People keep saying that,
and his head just keeps gettin
bigger and bigger, and I think
we need to bring him down now.
-I mean, that's hard
because he just physically
already has a pretty large head.
-He does.
-Yeah.
-He's a large human being.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, I was wondering because,
you know, I think
one of the things that draws
a lot of people to "The Voice"
is the very fun,
lighthearted trash talking
you guys use amongst yourselves.
Do you ever have to, like,
tone it down when you
get around people that
are non-"Voice" coaches?
-Oh, absolutely.
I will come back from --
You know, we shoot the blind
auditions, things like that,
for about 8 to 12 hours,
depending.
And so, I come home for dinner
I've got, you know, Priyanka
a couple friends over,
and I'm still in that zone
So I'm talking trash
at the table,
and everyone's like,
"Nick, like, chill, bro."
But it's a real thing.
It's like you got to leave
"The Voice" on the set
and come home
and be a nice, you know, host.
-When you come
to the dinner table,
do you insist
that your chair starts
with its back to everybody
yeah?
-Yeah, absolutely.
-And then you turn around
based on smell.
-And then, if they
say something interesting --
And if they say
something interesting,
then I turn my chair around.
-It's conversation-based.
That makes sense.
[ Both laugh ]
You had a mega mentor,
Snoop Dogg...
-Yeah.
-...and I want to ask,
how was your time
spent with him?
-He's brilliant.
You know, he's obviously
a legend, and he is, I think
best known for his rapping
obviously.
But his, you know, production,
his awareness
of just musicality.
He's like a record player.
Like, he knows every single song
ever recorded, it seems.
And he smells great.
[ Laughter ]
-He does? Yeah, he does
have a very unique...
-Smell.
-A very upbeat odor.
-Yeah, it's wonderful.
-Yeah.
-It's just...yeah.
-Yeah, you just kind of feel -
I don't know
if it's crazy to say this.
You can kind of tell
when he's in the room.
-Yes, totally.
And I think the whole crew
myself, we're all very happy
-Did you -- Did he have
any of your tequila?
Is that something when you hav
guests around, do you say,
"Hey, you know,
I've got this Villa One thing.
I'd love for you guys
to have a taste"?
-No, I sent him some after
-Gotcha.
-But I have --
I've brought the Villa One
to set for the other coaches
And I think John has a winery,
and Blake has a vodka.
So Kelly's the only one that
has to launch her own something.
-Right.
-And then we've got basicall
a whole barback covered
with just the coaches.
-Well, that is --
I think when we're talking about
music and musicians,
it's obviously very important,
from what I've read,
historically,
to have a well-stocked bar
So they've certainly picke
the right people.
-Yeah, they certainly have
-[ Laughs ]
I'm surprised.
Does Blake really have a vodka
-Mm-hmm.
That's --
I can't remember the name of i
right now, but, yes, he does
And, you know, he likes it
He likes to enjoy his --
[ Laughter ]
-Blake does seem to like
Blake stuff.
That's, uh...
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-He does. His thing, though.
-Does he make it
in, like, a bathtub?
What is his vodka like?
[ Laughter ]
-Don't make me laugh.
-Oh, right.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
It's always a pleasure to talk
to you, and do get well soon
-Thank you.
Great to talk to you.
All the best.